okay so huh what have you done that's my
line
yeah I see I segwayed in the beginning
to that where did yes but that's
Adventure Time because you can just do
stuff like that and it doesn't have to
make any sense
can't argue that logic man is that hair
cut short
I'm just so blown away how sure it is
I'm I'm sorry no yeah at least you still
have here so we are talking about what
have you done which is another Ice King
episode which I he's like in half the
episode season so many of them um I I
can see why he's a fascinatingly
hilariously pathetic character I mean
he's just he's very likable and how like
just just pathetic he is I mean there's
no other word I can use her he's just a
pathetic character oh who just wants
friends yeah so see you do kind of
identify with a little bit more he just
doesn't know the right way to do it and
he wants he wants love they never knows
how to do it say oh he tries to take it
by force it's normally done it made us
how you got your wife but classic
cavemen rules but yeah I mean and so the
funny thing is that the last I came here
as the last episode or whatever but the
last time I saw a bubblegum like she was
kind of psychotic so when this one
started off I'm just like is this like
an arc she's going through say she's
just going totally insane but then it's
like oh there actually is kind of a
reason for it but yeah so I guess the
moral is just now I guess it's not never
trust everybody because why not cuts a
prison like do what is cuz I was
seriously like I'm gonna friggin hate
the Ice King if he really just lied to
him the whole time because I'm like
there's just nothing likable about of
that but he didn't know he was it's it's
for those who don't remember it's an
episode where bubblegum has them capture
the Ice King and puts on her pink
gauntlets of pain and says that she's
going to beat him to get these
Howell's out of him even though he's not
aware he's done anything wrong and
technically he didn't do anything wrong
so Finn and Jake feel really bad and
they let him go and lock themselves up
because it's you know locking him up
it's against their code and they did the
wrong thing but then it turns out that
he accidentally sprinkled loves it like
ice dandruff or something like that was
beard yeah on the people and that gets
them spreading some sort of ice plague
where they all start to turn the ice and
the only thing that can cure it
naturally is cries of pain from the
person that started it so so then they
go in with the Ice King thinking that he
has friends now because they let him out
and he's so happy but then Finn acts
like he he acts like he's dead was at it
yeah he acts like he died yeah and that
gives the Ice King so angry he screams
and that breaks everybody out and then
then Finn feels bad because it was such
a short amount of time that he mourned
and then Jake's like oh I would mourn
for you and carries him off mourning
which it's got so HUD I found that and
being surprisingly kind of touch I don't
know why there's something about the way
just carry on it's like oh I don't care
for you let's do it right now it's like
he's not even really doing it like that
you know realistic yeah well as
realistic as a dog that can change
anything would know but about like the
way the music was and the colors and
then sir walking away and just I don't
know there's something Stu strangely
kind of sweet about that about that
ending even though this is really
connect to too much vicious like oh no
that's just that's cool it's like
they're just playing
what great buds they are and how they
say we miss each other what was gone so
I don't know I it was a cute ethnic um I
like that they bring up in there
Finn and Jake you do all this stuff and
everything and what happens when they
just blindly follow an order without any
explanation they ran to catch the Ice
King and to bring him back in to torture
them and they're like okay and then also
they're like wait a minute should we
really be doing this is this
actually the right thing what has he
done and to me it brought the question
up do you just blindly follow what
you're told or should you kind of
question it a bit I always find that
because there's a few like I finds what
a couple people in I mean like anything
I'm always like trying to find the
balance but like there's some people
were anytime I ask them do something
that's always why why well I mean it's
like just just trust me and do it for a
moment you know it's like it'll work out
okay just trust me you gotta do it and
then there's others that like you said
they should ask why yeah you know like
can you avoid somebody used to do with
the producers a lot why me at a cameo I
just did see if they would ask I I
wouldn't tell them what it was for or
why and I think the strangest one I
think it was like nothing professor old
versus new or something I was just like
Benz I I need you to take shaving cream
be naked and act like you're about to
shave your pubes and he's finally just
like there's just as long pause he's
like okay I gotta ask
so any news in the video if ever wants
to see that I don't actually show
everything but and of course he agrees
to it but well you know because he and I
have an understanding and open
understanding that every french person
does yeah you'll know that about French
people they're they're all horny skunks
skunks you see Pepe LePew no that's true
and I found out in France he's actually
Italian it is interesting darn Italians
I guess so in French and because it's
like in France is like what do you do
it's a oh well to us Italians are horny
so we'll do that
that's what Benz I said a way then I'm
using his words so if that's false I'm
sorry French and/or Italian people but
that that's what I heard but can French
people defeat an evil ocean
can French people to feed an evil ocean
yes
I don't know a history of such being
done you should find out actually you
should ask him to do that
ask him to feed an evil ocean and see if
yes what what the hell are you talking
about love let's pretend this last
couple seconds never happened and
instead bring it back to the episode umm
no screw that what the hell were you
talking about
so actually another thing I really liked
in this episode was that you know you
have Finn and Jake and if you notice
Jake is just like he's kind of oblivious
to the whole thing going on here
Finn's like what's going on yeah sure
he's always like just yeah whatever
let's just do it let's just go where
where are we the Candy Kingdom
and these fins like no no not at all cuz
they were in the wrong I get the feeling
that if Finn wasn't around again this is
sort of what looks er complete Sinbad
Jake
like if somebody said let's just go kill
a bunch of people or Jake would be like
okay if he thought he could have fun
with it you know so I think Finn is
probably really good too like Sara help
you know like no Jake we should be doing
this okay like he'll just blindly go for
something if you think something is fun
the good and bad side as he thinks most
anything is fun so do you think that
like Jake may have had a dark past
almost like a criminal past
maybe I mean it is sort of like um
Marceline like she'll just do anything
she doesn't care if it's good or bad so
just do it cuz it's fun but I think
because Finn and Jacob she doesn't
really have many friends if any friends
and Finn and Jake are really close buds
so because of that you know he's willing
to follow him and agree with him much
more and you know he in finned is a good
kid you know he has to do good things so
that's why so do it but I gotta feel it
Jake fill him with like the wrong crowd
he would just like if it was fun he
would just do it oh yeah I could see
that usually even if it was just like
totally you're hurting people that's why
I think he's usually slower to catch on
to like the morality stuff but Finn is
always there to pick
on that yeah so yeah I mean a solid
episode on count with you that I think
it is sort of good to question wait if
someone just asked me something why
should I necessarily do it especially if
you doubt it
yeah I think that's the big thing um
then is just so trusting of his friends
that he'll jump at the chance to do
anything for him and sometimes you
should question why am i grabbing this
person and taking him hostage
what him as I'm sure you have done many
times whenever you grab a person and
take them hostage of course again how
you met your wife Ephraim oh yeah of
course
and the times you ask me to take people
hostage and fun Saturday nights don't
you oh yeah come over sometime haha I
get feeling if I say no I'll end up
going there anyway because of what you
do and how you do it and now you're
going to do it too so we can play a
board game
just like the Ice King I'll make pieces
out of my teeth is that what he did yeah
yeah that's very funny I totally missed
that part um but yeah no I I think it's
good it's good to question stuff um you
know and I mean that I think that's it
they should have just waited I think was
probably the best thing to cowering from
it because like she's about to tell them
and then like she gets interrupted
manfried yeah okay who was in the first
episode that you know I would say like I
saw that thing before if I couldn't
remember okay so I so manfried is the
name of the pinata okay is it a boy or a
girl
Jonah I have no idea I mean the word man
is in there so you would think boy but I
could not tell um he thinks way too deep
about these things maybe talking pinata
oh well you know we're doing via logs
about the damn show we got to talk about
something and I want to know the gender
of that pinata does it have a Tootsie
Roll at the bottom or a fortune cookie
III don't know what did they put fortune
cookies and daddies anything else you
got for this episode
no I've never like pain into hurts
well Wow you busted me about attacking
an evil ocean but you're talking about
pinatas with fortune cookies and there
was at least a segue into that my friend
a sake way into that yeah my friend kind
of my friend hey no no I'm not gonna do
no done no no what about the sake well
yeah so what's the sake wait nope
they're not my hero anymore that's you
fail at it that's just bad